[Music]
vaccines have saved
millions of lives in the past century
for now they're the best way out of this
crisis but there are exciting new
prospects waiting in the wings
the practice of vaccinating dates back
thousands of years
through rabbit spines powdered cow pox
and fearless scientists
today viral vectors and mrna technology
have been instrumental in fighting covet
19
and another technique could give more
hope
dna-based vaccines the beauty is that
scientists can design them on a computer
in a matter of hours
but people are worried about their own
dna being altered
italy is said to start trials of a
vaccine based on a dna fragment next
month
its drug regulator having approved the
covert evacs inoculation
more on the safety issue in a bit first
a little history lesson
as early as the 10th century in china
secretions from smallpox pustules were
dried and rubbed into superficial
scratches in the skin
or inhaled this is considered the first
inoculation
using attenuated pathogens to cause a
reaction by the immune system
in the 1770s english physician edward
jenner discovered that people
infected with cow pox which was
relatively harmless
did not contract the much more deadly
smallpox disease
in 1796 he vaccinated an eight-year-old
boy with pus from a milkmaid's cowpox
lesions
six weeks later the boy proved to be
immune
hence the name vaccine from vaca the
latin word for
cow
[Music]
originally vaccines were based on
injecting or administering small doses
of attenuated live or dead viruses into
the body
the immune system then attacked them and
created antibodies
and subsequently an immunity
with more complex viruses such as sars
cov2
a roundabout method is necessary
[Music]
that's why research teams try to produce
only certain fragments of one viral
protein
the spike protein which when safely
introduced to the body
would stimulate an immune response
genetically manipulated dna and rna
vaccines are also being tested
here the body produces a protein by
itself that triggers an immune reaction
another possibility is the viral vector
vaccine
in this case a harmless virus is
disguised as the sars cov2 virus
the immune system responds and remembers
the characteristics
[Music]
side effects of vaccinations are usually
limited to a bit of swelling or
mild symptoms for a few days permanent
vaccine damage occurs in very few of
those vaccinated
and the belief that vaccinations lead to
autism has been disproven by many
studies
viva is a professor of virology at the
university of geesen
just for the record dna vaccines get
alarm bells ringing for some people
just how safe are they
well actually there's been a lot of
studies meanwhile and
i would even say surprisingly um they
found
very little integration some studies
just found
zero of it although they thought clearly
found the dna in the organisms
so apparently they seem to be safe
but apart from the close to zero results
i mean is there is there something to be
concerned about there
well yeah you always have to keep an eye
on that that's for sure and this is why
there's all these safety studies after
a vaccine has been rolled out to just
observe for long
longer term effects if you want and
you there's nothing in biology there's
nothing you can exclude to 100 percent
but just to keep that in a perspective
vaccines like if you use an a dna virus
vector is in fact also a dna vaccine
it's just enclosed in a virus shell
but from uh the point on when it had it
has entered the cell it's basically the
same as a dna vaccine
and i guess we can't be 100 yet because
they're not ready for humans they're
being tested on animals yes correct
yeah there's two animal vaccines out at
the time
um what sort of animals and what sort of
results
have been achieved there well one is for
horses about
west nile virus and the other is for
salmon it's called infectious
hematopoietic necrosis virus
which is a rhaptovirus well related to
rabies basically
and in both cases they found them to be
safe and efficient
this is why they are licensed and you
can can give them as a vet
so apparently that seems sorry
i was just going to say if they're safe
and efficient and uh
proving quite successful why are dna
vaccines lagging behind other sorts of
vaccines then
i think exactly because of the concerns
you just expressed
and these are real concerns no doubt
about this
and they have to be checked on and on
and but
safety is always during all those
clinical studies the first issue
the first thing to be checked rather
than efficiency which comes later on
and um as i said so far it seems to be
okay
but the other ones are most of them
apart from the messenger rna vaccines
are like established platforms all you
had to do was to put the
your favorite sas core on virus 2 and
you turn
on it and let it express by your vector
and then off you go
so that's easier because there's always
there's over already pla
licensed vaccines on these platforms
okay well let's compare the mrna
vaccines to the dna
vaccines and how they both work the dna
vaccine introduces genetic code of a
piece of a virus like the spike protein
for example into a person's cells
just like an mrna vaccine
but it then has to get into the nucleus
where it's transcribed into
mrna which instructs the cell to produce
the spike protein
priming the immune system for the real
virus so the
dna has to get into the cell nucleus to
make the mrna
why not just take the mrna vaccine in
the first place
well that's perfectly correct the only
thing is simply messenger rna
vaccines are much more expensive like 10
times as much at least
so it's also a question of economy and
dna is just
very very simple to make and very cheap
to produce in
huge amounts
it is something that the people are
genuinely worried about though injecting
that dna
into the nucleus of their cells i mean
can it harm cells can it alter the
genome
um well in fact if you have a vaccine
you have to harm the cells to some
extent because
um besides the expression of the antigen
you need to have a little injury to be
set
in order to alarm the immune system so
this is uh always goes hand in hand if
you want
and in fact what what we do is we apply
the dna
as an electric shock so you get a little
little shock yes with a with the device
it looks like a pistol it has
a certain amount of electrodes there's
still experiments how many there will be
in the end
and um after this little shock the dna
has entered the cell not necessarily the
nucleus that will be the next step and
will not happen in all the cells
but when cells are dividing the nucleus
is
dissolving actually and it's in the open
and it will kind of when the cells have
divided form again
and then this plus with dna is ending up
in the nucleus
you're making it sound better and better
with the electric shock and pistol but
tell me how will a dna seem i've seen
videos of people
they survived it yeah they survive
that's good to hear
tell me how a dna vaccine could actually
deal with something like mutations which
is
on everyone's minds right now
i think with the dna vaccine one is as
flexible as with a messenger rna vaccine
or whether
don't an adenovirus vector for example
all you need is your new sequence either
you
insert if it's just one mutation you can
insert it like
by hand in the lab everybody could do
that in the lab
or if it's more mutations all over the
gene then you just exchange the whole
gene but this is basically
normal lab work and not much of a
problem
you heard it from freedman weber a
professor of virology at the university
of geesen thank you very much
you're welcome thank you and let's get
you over to our science correspondent
derek williams
he's been looking into your questions on
the coronavirus
how does the pfizer biontech vaccine
work
i've answered this before but the
question is posted again and again so i
guess it's maybe time to go over the
details again
um two of the vaccines that have now
been widely approved
one developed by biontech and pfizer and
one produced by moderna are what are
called a
messenger rna or mrna vaccines
now the technology behind them has been
at the focus
of a lot of research for decades but but
this is the first time they've received
widespread approval from
health care authorities um unlike
vaccines based on traditional platforms
ones that for example use inactivated
versions of the virus
the biontech pfizer vaccine leads to an
immune response in the body
by delivering information in the form
of a special molecule a messenger rna
mrna molecules are are single stranded
chains and what are called nucleotides
that fulfill
a very important function in cells
they're they're kind of the blueprints
for
making proteins and act as messengers
between
a cell's headquarters in the nucleus and
its protein building factories
out in the cytoplasm and hence the name
but the protein these new mrna vaccines
encode for
isn't a human one it's a protein made by
the coronavirus
and when that mrna is injected
it causes your cells to begin making
that
viral protein and that viral protein
provokes an immune response just as if
you'd caught
covet 19. sending in the pretty simple
quick to produce mrna code molecules
to make these complicated proteins and
getting the body to do the work
is a great solution to a complex problem
and
and there are high hopes that mrna
vaccines
which seem to have finally come into
their own um are now set to to
revolutionize a range of fields in
medicine
[Music]
and keep sending in your questions to
our youtube channel thanks for watching
stay safe and see you again soon
[Music]